FROM THE SOUTH.
THE TOWN OF 200,000 PEOPLE, YOU
CAN SIGH, LEVELED BY THE RUSSIAN
ATTACK.
>>> UKRAINIANS NEAR THE NUCLEAR
PLANT THAT WAS SHELLED BY
RUSSIAN FORCES ARE FLEEING WEST
BY THE THOUSANDS.
SO MANY ARE TRYING TO GET OUT
THEY ARE OVERWHELMING THE
TRANSPORT SYSTEM.
SAM KILEY IS ON THE GROUND IN
NEARBY DENAPRO, UKRAINE.
>> Reporter: A COLLECTIVE BREATH
IS HELD AS A LONG-AWAITED
EVACUATION TRAIN SLOWS TO A
HALT.
THE ODDS OF GETTING OUT
DETERMINED BY ACCESS TO A
CARRIAGE DOOR.
POLICE STRUGGLE TO CONTAIN THE
CROWD.
ALL ARE DESPERATE TO FLEE WEST.
THE MASS EVACUATION OF ZA
E
ZAPORIZHZHIA IS BECAUSE OF THE
CAPTURE OF THE NUCLEAR PLANT.
THIS THE BIGGEST IN EUROPE.
THEY SAY YOU ARE ENDANGERING THE
SECURITY OF THE ENTIRE WORLD.
ATTENTION.
STOP SHOOTING AT A NUCLEAR
HAZARDOUS FACILITY.
ATTENTION.
STOP IT.
THERE IS NOW A DISREGARD FOR
NUCLEAR SAFETY AS WELL AS LIVES
IN CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
BEING BOTTOM BOARDED BY RUSSIA.
SCENES HAVEN'T BEEN SEEN LIKE
THIS SINCE THE SECOND WORLD WAR.
IT HAS BEEN ACCELERATED HERE
BECAUSE PEOPLE BELIEVE BASED ON
THE EVIDENCE THEY HAVE SEEN
ELSEWHERE IN UKRAINE, IT IS
CIVILIANS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
TARGETED IN VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
INVASION.
WHEN RUSSIAN TROOPS CAME CLOSER
TO ZAPORIZHZHIA, I DECIDED IT
WAS BETTER TO GET MY FAMILY OUT
BEFORE THEY ENTERED THE CITY
ITSELF.
>> Translator: WE HOPE THAT WE
CAN MAKE IT ON THE TRAIN TODAY
BECAUSE THIS MORNING PEOPLE
DIDN'T LET US IN EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE A BABY.
>> Reporter: THIS IS A WAR THAT
SEPARATES HUSBANDS FROM WIVES,
FATHERS FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
MEN BETWEEN 18 AND 60 CANNOT
LEAVE.
THEY ARE NEEDED FOR THE FIGHT.
YOU ARE STAYING HERE?
.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: SO THIS IS
GOOD-BYE, TEMPORARILY.
WELL, I HOPE IN A WEEK OR TWO
YOU CAN BE BACK TOGETHER AGAIN.
MORE THAN A MILLION HAVE FLED SO
FAR.
BUT THEY ARE ENDURING FREEZING
CONDITIONS IN HOPE OF A TRAIN TO
SAFETY.
BUT THIS 80-YEAR-OLD IS STAYING
ON.
HE IS A FORMER PARATROOPER IN
THE SOVIET ARMY.
>> Translator: I MADE MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS.
I'M A HUNTER WITH 40 YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE.
I HAVE A MEDAL LEFT FROM THE
USSR.
I'M STAYING.
I HATE THEM.
ALL THE INVADERS BECAUSE OF
THIS, NOT TO MENTIONED FACT THAT
MY GRANDSON WAS BOMBED FOR A
WEEK IN KHARKIV.
>> Reporter: THOSE PEOPLE WHO
MAKE IT ON BOARD NOW FACE A
600-MILE JOURNEY TO LA LEAVE.
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T, TIME AND
LUCK MAY BE RUNNING OUT.
NOW, JOHN AND BRIANNA, ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS FOR CIVILIANS IN
THIS COUNTRY, AS WE HEARD FROM
MATTHEW CHANCE, THE RANDOM
ATTACKS ON CITIES.
IN THE CASE OF MARIUPOL
COMPLETELY SURROUNDED.
A TERRIFIC AMOUNT OF EFFORT
BEING MADE BY THE GOVERNMENT OF
THE WORLD TO TRY TO GET
HUMANITARIAN CORRIDORS ORGANIZED
SO CIVILIANS CAN GET OUT.
THE RUSSIANS ANNOUNCE THEY WOULD
ALLOW CIVILIANS OUT BUT ONLY
INTO RUSSIAN TERRITORY.
A SUGGESTION THAT'S BEEN
REJECTED OUTRIGHT BY UKRAINIANS
AS A PRETTY CYNICAL MOVE.
AND I HAVE TO SAY IT'S VERY MUCH
PART OF THE RUSSIAN PLAYBOOK.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT IN CONFLICTS
ELSEWHERE.
THEY USE THOSE AS CEASE-FIRES TO
REGROUP AND THIS TIME MARKED
CIVILIANS WHILE THEY ARE UNDER
PROTECTION MILITARILY.
.
>> USING THEM AS SHIELDS.
TOUGH TO WATCH.
IMPORTANT, THOUGH.
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY SAYS IT IS
HOLDING FIRE SO CIVILIANS CAN
EVACUATE IN FOUR CITIES.
BUT UKRAINE IS PUSHING BACK.
HE SAID THOSE CITIES ARE STILL
BEING BOMBED.
MANY OF THOSE CIVILIANS ARE
GIVEN NO CHOICE BUT TO HEAD TO
RUSSIA, AS SAM WAS JUST
EXPLAINING, THROUGH BELARUS.
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMITTEE OF
THE RED CROSS TWEETED YESTERDAY,
PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN TERROR IN
MARIUPOL, DESPERATE FOR SAFETY.
TODAY'S ATTEMPT TO START
EVACUATING AN ESTIMATED 200,000
PEOPLE HAS FAILED.
THE FAILED ATTEMPTS UNDERSCORE
THE ABSENCE OF A DETAILED AND
FUNCTIONING AGREEMENT BETWEEN
PARTIES TO THE CONFLICT.
NOW A MEMBER OF THE RED CROSS.
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT IT IS LIKE,
WHAT PEOPLE IN MARIUPOL ARE
ENDURING AND WHAT THEY ARE UP
AGAINST WHEN THEY ARE TRYING TO
LEAVE.
>> THANK YOU, BRIANNA.
THE SITUATION IN MARIUPOL IS
DESPERATE.
PEOPLE HAVE NOW IN THEIR 10th
DAY WITHOUT WATER, WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY, LIVING IN SHELTERS.
SHELTERS ARE PACKED.
I MEAN, THE ESSENTIALS ARE
MISSING.
A LOT OF HEALTH CARE NEEDS AS
WELL.
AND PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE A SAFE
PASSAGE TO LEAVE MARIUPOL AND
ANY OTHER LOCATION WHERE
HOSTILITIES ARE ACTIVE.
ICRC IS WILLING TO FACILITATE
THOSE PASSAGES PROVIDED THAT
PARTIES AGREE ON THE TERMS ON
SPECIFIC ACTIONABLE AND CONCRETE
TERMS, INCLUDING LOCATIONS,
TIMES, CIVILIANS WHO WISH TO
LEAVE VOLUNTARILY BUT ALSO
WHETHER ANY HUMANITARIAN AID CAN
BE BROUGHT IN WHILE CIVILIANS
WHO CHOOSE TO LEAVE ARE LEAVING.
>> WHAT DOES ARE ISSUE THAT NEED
TO DO HERE REALLY?
WHAT DO THEY NEED TO AGREE TO SO
THAT CIVILIANS ARE NOT KILLED AS
THEY ESCAPE?
WHAT RUSSIA IS PROPOSING RIGHT
NOW IS JUST NOT REALISTIC.
>> WE'RE SPEAKING TO BOTH
PARTIES.
WE'RE FACILITATING THE DIALOGUE
BETWEEN THEM SO THAT THESE SAFE
PACKAGES HAVE THE NECESSARY
GUARANTEES FOR CIVILIANS TO
LEAVE WHILE IT'S SAFE FOR THEM
TO LEAVE.
AND THE ICRC IS READY TO
ACCOMPANY THOSE CIVILIANS
LEAVING THE CONVOYS PROVIDED
PARTIES AGREE AMONG EACH OTHER.
ICRC CANNOT BE A GRANTOR FOR ANY
CEASE-FIRE OR SECURITY RELATED
TO THOSE SAFE PACKAGES.
>> SO, MIRELLA, THERE ARE
REPORTS RIGHT NOW OF RUSSIA
MINING, PUTTING MINES ALONG THE
ESCAPE ROUTES IN MARIUPOL.
IS THERE EVIDENCE OF THAT?
>> WE HAVEN'T SEEN -- WE'RE IN
DISCUSSION WITH BOTH PARTIES.
FOR THE TIME BEING, OF COURSE
THERE IS VIOLENCE EVERYWHERE.
HOSTILITIES ARE EVERYWHERE.
WE NEED TO BE VERY CLEAR ON THE
ROUTINGS.
THESE CONVOYS WILL TAKE SO
CIVILIANS CAN TAKE WHERE THE
HOSTILITIES ARE VERY ACTIVE LIKE
IN MARIUPOL AND OTHER PLATES AND
THAT THEY ARE SAFE DOING THAT.
SO SAFE PACKAGE IS MANDATORY
UNDER INTERNATIONAL HUMANITARIAN
LAW, AND BOTH PARTIES WOULD NEED
TO AGREE ON PROVIDING SAFE
PACKAGE